The joe rogan experience.
Pendular listen,
I love the rent and if you want to listen to it pendula at Sunday schools is
fucking amazing.
I want to meet him so bad.
We didn't figure this out 10 years ago,
but come on.
That's a great,
that's a great Rancho.
De I'm wasting your time.
Gave me the talk to you.
We're talking to you.
I'm talking to you right now.
Welcome to me about what?
It's a business.
What the fuck do you want?
Nobody knows.
Prison is a business and that's what it is.
It's a fucking business guys.
It's important.
When a guy like Jillette greatly,
I said,
boy,
you break the fucking law.
You go to jail.
You sell weed against the law in 2010 bales,
you get caught.
You go to jail.
I went to jail.
I'm responsible.
I learned how to fucking.
That's it.
What are you going to do?
There's a law.
You cannot fucking do it.
You're going to go to jail.
Jail and prison are a fucking business.
They're a business.
That's why you didn't get a ticket driving with the phone.
How much they tell you this.
How much they tell you this,
I don't know.
$25 until you go down to La County and it's $225 because you've got to pay the
court costs,
the prison fee,
the judges vacation.
It's a,
it's a fucking business guys.
They're going to raise the taxes now for fucking parking tickets.
It's a business.
What the fuck you want me to do?
This is the oldest conversation.
The book,
they should have legalized this after they shot Kennedy.
They didn't.
We fucking fortunate that we live in California and we don't have to abide by
this.
When was the last time you were at a stone?
They kicked the door down.
Joe Rogan.
How about you my friend?
So all this shit,
you guys talk about them kicking the doors.
The feds.
I've never seen it.
I can go get weed every day.
Stop scaring these fucking white kids and getting them talking.
This is nonsense.
This is nonsense talk.
They should currently with Ya.
I never drink it.
So what?
So who gives a fuck?
It applies for everything going.
There's a lot of people who are in jail.
They get out every day and a DNA or whatever.
You break the law.
You sell five pounds a week,
you got to go to jail.
It's a business.
You didn't do nothing wrong,
but it's a business.
They have guidelines.
If you get caught with dirty 28 grams of blow,
you have to do a certain amount of fucking time.
You get caught with a quarter ounce of weed.
You have to do a certain amount of time.
You got caught with it.
Why are you crying to me for you got caught when I was a criminal for 30 years.
You some you get caught with blow.
We eat or blow.
No,
you follow me.
There's a way to do it and there's a way,
not Tyler fucker.
You're going to get caught with fucking weed and not think you're going to go to
jail.
If you live in fucking Ohio and in fucking Kentucky or wherever you're going to
go to jail.
I kind of see your point,
but I also see his,
cause it's a,
it's an important man.
It's brilliant though.
It's important.
It's not together with Fallon and the presence hip or what?
I don't give a fuck dog.
You don't care if I'm smoking.
Look,
look here.
This is what I think about your whole drug thing.
Look like the same thing I rub my balls with for the last 32 years with the
sativas and the bullshit.
Just get high dog.
You'd be breakthrough.
Much drama to the gift that God gave us.
A getting high.
You got too much drama.
I can't.
I've got to put a Dang at the end of the joint to be cool while you're smoking
on the fucking electronic cigarette
and electronic.
What?
I'm smoking.
Think about that.
Okay?
That's all that matters at the end of the week.
That's all that matters.
Fuck.
And people want to be intelligent all the time.
We can't wait to see you on the stage tonight.
No fucking stupid rare for people.
I'm three out of four people in there for rape and murder.
What do you,
what are you telling me?
Showing me pause.
Calm down.
Who gives a fuck?
And to show people that you give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't want people locked up in jail for weed.
You know what my favorite thing Joe came in here?
Jack boot thugs.
Violin fucking haul you away for you a little.
I'm accountancy Pencil comedian for 20 years.
I drink from time to time.
Did ever get behind the car when I'm drunk,
I got a Dui.
That's a choice.
You make these all the choices you make,
bro.
So,
uh,
what are we getting that I know it's illegal.
I know it should be legal and I know that the John Lennon's want to make a
comeback,
but for today,
2000 foot to tonight.
Well for today,
if you get caught smoking and fucking in New York,
you're going to jail.
I don't care what you said,
bro.
I love hearing you talk.
I know.
Fuck.
I'm going to put up with this nonsense.
I Love Penn.
Jillette but that'll give them,
I was going off yesterday.
I was saying how Joey Diaz will get mad about ketchup.
About,
oh,
this is going to be wanting to come up with this fucking Heinz Ketchup or ranch.
Have you ever heard him talking about ranch?
Oh,
I fucking hate rant.
I don't know how the fuck people go eat that shit.
I don't know how people could be ranch.
I like when I go to a place and I say,
you all,
you have wings and they say cubs are ranch.
I get up and leave even if I don't get the wings.
Because if you're going to serve wings ranch,
I don't want to do business with you.
I want to do business with you.
I'm very easy.
I'm very fucking easy.
So if you fuck up pork fried rice,
what do we got to talk about?
Wings must be done with Gucci.
Gucci is,
yeah,
like the way of,
they invented in Buffalo,
New York,
and you got to do some electric.
Who would original.
You're going to show up with that Ras.
That's the most like somebody asked the same wage ranch is starting to replace
ketchup.
Yeah,
that's good.
If you're fucking hillbilly and you want the taste of acid in your mouth all
fucking day.
I hate that fucking rich.
Don't put it close to me and I'll put it around me and see the blue cheese with
wings and go fuck him up.
That's the next year.
All right,
please
give me a fucking,
I'll rats would fuck away.
I can say,
Ooh,
Jesus.
Fuck your mother.
Go fuck him.
I didn't know this shit fucking got to give me branch with my wigs.
That's a mother fuckers.
I'm stoked.
Fucking
blue cheeses,
wigs.
Oh,
fucking going to get me shit.
I lead my people around the ranch like going in and I sit around me.
Do me that favor,
right?
Freaks and Geeks.
Lovers and children.
What's going on ladies and gentlemen?